[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro de vip et la personnalité évinois
ce qui est avec nous pour ce numéro
c'est l'humoriste arnaud tsamère bonjour
alors pendant les minutes qui vont
suivre on va parler de vous de votre
parcours de votre actualité
vous êtes né à bordeaux nous arriver
très vite dans les yvelines à 7 ans ce
lien vous l'avez toujours avec le
département ouais oui oui clairement je
suis assez attaché à règle générale aux
endroits où j'ai vécu et
le fait est que j'ai vécu la plus grande
partie de ma vie dans les yvelines donc
je suis évidemment attaché aux yvelines
pour plein de raisons des raisons
personnelles des raisons
professionnelles
donc j'aime j'adore y revenir non j'ai
pas coupé j'ai pas du tout coupé les
ponts et d'ailleurs je vis pas à paris
même je vis dans le donne dans le
sud-ouest pour être prêt de l'a13 et
près des voies là pour pouvoir rentrer à
la maison plus vite alors arnaud tsamère
avant d'être humoriste il fait des
études de droit mais cette même diplômé
de droit des affaires
mais vous découvrir un spectacle
d'improvisation ça change tout bah oui
très clairement très clairement ça je ne
me doutais pas que en allant voir ce
spectacle à la fac donc à 300 studios
je me doutais pas que ça allait changer
ma vie ouais mais mais au sens littéral
vraiment sage qui vous a plu qu'est ce
qui vous a fait ce déclic
bah c'est en fait quand j'ai vu ce
spectacle déjà je me suis beaucoup marré
et puis c'était très ludique
il y avait plein de se les matchs
d'impro ces deux équipes avec dédé des
maillots de hockey sur glace un arbitre
c'était très coloré très très très
ludique et je voyais des gens vraiment
prendre beaucoup de plaisir à faire ce
spectacle et nous spectateurs ont ri aux
larmes
je me suis dit tiens c'est quelque chose
je savais qu'il y avait un cours d'un
pro il y avait quelque chose qui était
organisée à la fac donc dès le lendemain
je suis allé m'inscrire et et c'est là
que j'ai rencontré les gens qui
m'accompagnent encore aujourd'hui qui
allait devenir ma main plus que des amis
ma famille à artistique et voilà et puis
et puis ça a changé ma vie puisque
quelques années plus tard j'ai décidé
d'en faire mon métier même vous le dit
ces gens là c'est déclic théâtre
j'imagine une idée qui quoi vous y
entrer sans problème
on vous ouvre grand
oui parce que parce que papy alain
degois
et comme ça il ouvre grande la porte à
qui veut à qui est motivée acquis envie
de bien faire et à partir de là il vous
donne sa confiance
immédiatement et non seulement sa
confiance mais toute la structure qu'il
a mis des dizaines d'années à monter il
la met à disposition voilà et moi j'en
ai profité entre guillemets je suis
rentré dans cette compagnie qui est ce
qu'il ya un fonctionnement très familial
aussi très clanique
j ai découvert des des gens motivés des
artistes talentueux des amis et voilà
j'étais effaré de voir l'énergie que
papy et son équipe mettait à créer des
spectacles à donner des cours de théâtre
des cours d un pro dans nos m'attraper
dans les environs je me suis très vite
senti cocooner et et guider dans cette
passion de la scène
et justement quand vous choisissez d'en
faire votre métier vos parents sont
inquiets pas pire assure comment ça se
passe
happy rassure ça c'est sûr les parents
inquiets non parce que quand je décide
ça c'est en 2001 j'ai 25 ou 26 ans j'ai
ma maîtrise de droit
j'ai deux ans d'expérience
professionnelle en entreprise donc à 25
26 ans quand on dit à ses parents mais
je vais faire à partir de maintenant je
vais faire ça il ya plus de top
y a plus d'autorité parentale il ya une
bonne chance et ils vous font pas
ressentir au fond d'eux peut-être se
dire vous il prend un risque si ça je
les ai sentis clairement mais mais mais
ils m'ont pas empêché où ils m'ont pas
ils ont essayé de me convaincre que
c'était une mauvaise idée
après je voyais bien au fond d'eux au
fond d'eux que il y avait une petite
inquiétude
et puis bon je sais pas de quoi sera
fait l'avenir mais jusqu'ici tout va
bien donc et papy je me souviens très
pour la petite anecdote avant de donner
ma démission
j'ai eu un je suis allé voir papy je lui
dis voilà j'envisage ça et on est resté
deux heures et deux heures pendant
lesquelles il m'a dit ça fait des
semaines que j'attends ce rendez vous je
savais que tu viendrais me voir pour me
dire ça la veille il avait senti et puis
mais il me dit voilà je vais t'expliquer
par a plus b comment moi je vais pas te
laisser tomber commande et clique va
t'apporter la structure nécessaire pour
te lancer et ça a duré deux heures sur
sorti leur disant ok je prend la bonne
décision
il a rassuré ouais ça m'a rassuré c'est
pour ça que quand on me dit c'est très
courageuse que tu as fait de
démissionner pour te lancer dans ce
spectacle à l'époque j'avais le
sentiment qui s'était pas du tout
courageux en fait c'était juste quelque
chose de viscéral contre il fallait que
je le fasse et et la structure déclic
théâtre
ma je veux dire c'est pas le cliché du
jeune artiste qui débarque à paris et
que son baluchon qui connaît personne et
c'est par là j'étais vraiment c'est
kader ouej était encadrée j'étais entre
de bonnes mains et je savais surtout
j'avais l'assurance que j'allais pouvoir
travailler tout de suite et justement
vous faites un premier spectacle incarne
au joaillier qui est aussi de déclic il
vous fallait aussi cet accompagnement
c'est vous qui êtes allé vers lui ou ses
anneaux qui vous à l'heure arnaud je les
rencontre et ça fait partie des des
personnes que j'ai rencontrées quand
j'ai commencé à faire de l'impro à la
fac donc ça a été tout de suite on a eu
tout de suite un lien très très fort
avec l'improvisation théâtrale et puis
arnaud c'est un artiste peut-être un des
artistes les plus talentueux que je
connais c'est un auteur compositeur
chanteur metteur en scène comédien pour
improvisateurs il sait tout faire c'est
un gars qui est né dans le dans le
spectacle avec fils de l'artiste dont
qui baigne littéralement dedans est tout
de suite il m'a tout de suite il m'a il
m'a accompagné aussi lui dans mais dans
mes premiers pas en one man show en
écrivant des textes pour moi à l'époque
je ne savais pas écrire lui savait le
faire et c'est lui qui a écrit mes
premiers textes et qui a écrit une bonne
partie de mon premier spectacle
là on a retrouvé dans nos archives
entation sur une scène
line was on est au festival de rock ou
encore et je propose qu'on regarde je
suis là pour honorer une promesse
une promesse que j'ai faite il ya un
mois et demi à mon meilleur ami rémy
rémy pardon je vais prendre un petit peu
de temps pour vous raconter tout ça
parce que croyez moi il s'agit d'une
histoire tout à fait singulière et puis
en même temps je vais la faire un petit
peu courte parce que sinon je n'aurai
pas le temps de faire autre chose et ce
serait dommage parce que c'est
précisément pour faire autre chose que
je suis là ce soir
donc voilà un jour j'étais dans la cour
de l'école et j'avais 8 ans et comme je
sens que je suis déjà en train de vous
perdre avec cette histoire je vais faire
un petit saut dans le temps un petit
saut de 24 ans pour en arriver à cette
fameuse soirée d'il ya un mois et demi
rémy donc qui entre-temps était devenu
mon meilleur ami nous avait tous réunis
au balto un petit café pmu du côté de
vincennes son qg comme il aimait à
l'appeler
oui je parle de rémy au passé parce
qu'il est mort et rémy nous avait réunis
au balto pour nous faire part de sa
décision de se lancer dans le spectacle
et vers 4 heures du matin quand rémy a
quitté le balto c'est l'avant dernière
fois que je le voyais jeudi l'avant
dernière parce qu'une heure et demie
après j'ai reçu un coup de fil de
stéphanie sa femme
je me souviendrai toute ma vie de ce
moment elle a dit d'une voix chevrotante
à l'opa de ces steph il ya un problème
non non c'est rémy pas vraiment il a eu
un accident de voiture non bah je sais
pas non je suis à l'hôpital
il est dans un sale état peut-être il te
réclament patrice merci voilà alors ça
peut vous paraître un petit peu décousu
mais j'ai pas jugé utile de vous dire
tout ce que moi je répondais en même
temps je me rends compte que vous avez
peut-être pas compris
sans mes phrases à moi mes phrases à moi
et en quoi tu es malade annoncé rémi qui
est malade quoi yves yumi mais il va
bien et la bagnole t à la gym là il va
s'en sortir il dit quelque chose
j'arrive tout de suite voilà c'est plus
clair
voilà on est en 2007
ch la claque la grèce sur quoi mon dieu
cliquez sur le look et la claque est
sûre non le sait c'est un spectacle qui
a beaucoup vécu après ça et alors c'est
c'est bizarre de voir cet extrait qui
était le but le tout début du spectacle
écrit qu'en fait c'est un extrait qui
est d'une tristesse infinie mais j'étais
obligé en début de spectacle j'étais
obligé de poser ce truc très triste
cette convention où j'expliquais que je
rende un hommage à mon pote morts et
puis derrière ça partait en délire et
etc
mais c'est marrant de voir ça c'est très
très rigolo là on a vu de la scène est
ce qui vous révèle au grand public on va
dire c'est qu'on demande qu'à en rire
oui est ce que vous l'avez ressenti
aussi pour découvrir l'autre sa mère à
lundi
très clairement on a oui oui j'ai bien
senti oui je les bien senti passer ça
bah oui pour la recharge de travail par
la reconnaissance du public le nom la
charge de travaux oui alors la charge de
travail était un peu
un peu forte avec cette émission parce
qu'on nous demandait beaucoup et en peu
de temps mais c'est surtout le fait que
ça ait marché très vite et très vite on
commença je me souviens comme si c'était
hier de la première fois qu'un petit
garçon et que sa maman m'a reconnu dans
la rue et et ça fait très bizarre et
puis et puis le lendemain pareil et puis
ça s'est jamais arrêté et là ça fait
bizarre oui ça fait on sent qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe à l'époque
j'ai joué mon spectacle ce spectacle là
je le jouais une fois par mois dans une
salle de 45 places et avec cette
émission ce même spectacle sans son
toucher une virgule
il a fui je les jouais l'olympia de
trois ans après donc oui évidemment que
c'est c'est que c'est vertigineux
est ce que vous faisiez le parallèle
entre votre scène et les sketchs que
vous voulez faire pour l'émission est ce
que certaines choses vous l'été astier
sur le plateau non non je non non je
sais c'était très différent en fait ce
que je propose est sûr ce n est pas ce
que mon spectacle c'était un spectacle
d'une heure et demie c'était un sketch
d'une heure et demie en fait c'était une
histoire d'une heure et demie d'ailleurs
on voit sur l'extrait c'est un peu
j'allais dire c'est un peu théâtral quoi
il n'y a pas de c'est une histoire qui
se met en place sur le long terme donc
et à la télé il fallait être efficace
sur cinq minutes 5 6 minutes tout de
suite donc c'était une autre écriture
donc n'y avait pas vraiment de pont
d'écriture ni même de jeu entre la les
sketches à la télé le spectacle sur
scène parce que vraiment ce sont des
deux exercices différents
est ce que vous attendiez à devenir un
tel pilier de l'émission on n'demande
qu'à en rire ah non bien sûr que non non
moi quand je me suis lancée dans
l'émission en fait au début
l'émission a été lancée en septembre
2010 moi j'y suis arrivé en deux mois
après je sois novembre 2010 et ce qui
m'a fait ce qui m'a convaincu d'y aller
c'est que je voyais olivier de benoist
kev adams qui commençait à devenir des
réguliers des piliers de l'émission et
je me suis dit merde
il ya un train qui passe peut-être que
si je monte pas dedans je vais le
regretter
au pire si je le rate si je me rate
c'est pas très grave
et j'ai bien fait je crois parce que
lorsque effectivement plus personne
personne n'a tenu rigueur à ceux qui
n'ont pas réussi dans cette émission est
d'ailleurs il y en a beaucoup qui ont
réussi d'une autre manière après donc on
ne tenait pas du tout rigueur aux gens
qui n'y arrivait pas en revanche ceux
qui arrivent et ceux qui arrivent à
passer les vagues à passer les semaines
et elles mêmes les années en ce qui me
concerne ça a été tout bénef donc avec
des sketches mémorable ouais avec new
way avec des sketches dont on parle
encore même parce qu'elle est le sketch
con con quand on se rappelle le plus
inscrites sous je faisais parler de la
bouffe j'avais avec des légumes
ce sketch là on en a encore parlé là il
ya quelques jours et je suis toujours
étonné en 2020 c'est un sketch qui date
de 2011 que j'ai écrit dans un hall
d'hôtel en avril 2011
et voilà qu'on voit les images voilà et
alors ça c'est ce sketch là il à dire
quand on vous en parle encore neuf ans
après c'est que il a quand même changé
des trucs coin vous battez le record de
l'émission ce jour là avec tous les
jeunes au possible
ouais mais j'avais était marrante cette
émission nous imposer un thème et
l'avocat de la frite et de la salade et
puis je me suis pris la tête très
longtemps et je me suis dit mais
l'avocat donc on parlait d'un avocat
juriste un homme de mes jeux aussi mais
l'avocat en fait c'est ça se bouffent
aussi comme l'afrique comme le veut et
puis voilà et puis l'idée elle est
partie comme ça mais mais je vous avoue
que quand j'arrive sur le plateau je
suis pas je suis pas serein parce que la
répétition s'est très mal passé parce
que j'avais pas les fruits et les
légumes à disposition qu'il a fallu je
le fasse à vide pour les cameramans pour
ans répète ça n'a fait rire personne
et quand je suis arrivé sur le plateau
je n'étais pas serein mais après voilà
il ya un truc un peu après magic qui se
passe et dans l'émission un moment vous
commencez à jouer en duo avec ben et
c'est ben là vous partez sur de la scène
on pourquoi
ensemble vous étiez indissociables au
bout d'un moment oui alors en fait les
duos qu'on fait chez ruquier
c'est en 2012 avec ben on se connaît
depuis 2004 on se connaît on s'apprécie
on s'aime beaucoup on a collaboré sur
des petites choses avant ruquier cette
complicité là on l'a on la travaille
chez chez ruquier on fait des sketches
qui marche très très fort et puis
quelques années après on se dit il faut
absolument qu'on aille où ça faisait dix
ans qu'on parlait de faire un spectacle
ensemble et il faut avancer dit faut
absolument aller au bout de cette de ce
fantasme laddh de monter sur scène
ensemble c'était le bon moment moi je
venais de finir mon spectacle il venait
de finir le sien et voilà et on a fait
ça mais c'est vraiment une
c'était un truc dont on parlait webdocu
plus de dix ans et quand on vous regarde
ce que vous êtes passés chez nous
notamment à montigny-le-bretonneux vous
vous amusez sur scène vous avez même du
mal à garder votre sérieux mais oui mais
oui mais parce que c'est l'homme qui me
fait le plus rire au monde n é
je suis tellement fan de ce gala est et
je me oui et puis je suis assez fragile
sur scène dans le sens où quand ça me
fait marrer j'ai du mal à me contenir et
lui a fait pareil donc ça donne des
choses un peu parfois ça donnait des
spectacles avec lui qui était un peu un
peu plus long que prévu
le temps qu'on
au calme nos fous rires j'ai public
pouvait voir un spectacle différent vous
connais sur scène mais ce qu'on sait
moins de vous si vous êtes un passionné
de sport automobile du sport tout court
des sports de secours fait des émissions
sur la vraie enfin des petits sketchs
sur la barre avec elle aussi cette
passion du sport c'est votre manière de
vous évader aussi en fait ma passion du
sport s'est massé ma vie c'est ma vie
avant même ma vie artistique en fait
gamin j'ai grandi avec des idoles
sportive avec des passions sportives et
pas du tout avec des icônes ou des
références artistiques
j'ai découvert ça plus tard quand je me
suis mis à ce métier à 25 ans mais mais
mais dès l'âge de 6 ans mais ma vraie
passion ma vraie mais je vais même aller
plus loin que ça c'était une c'est une
raison de vivre des gamins c'était j'ai
joué au foot en club dans les yvelines
pendant 18 ans je suis je suis je fais
du vélo depuis que j'ai 12 13 ans je me
prend je sais pas si j'aurais pu être
mais voilà je joue au tennis je joue je
pratique plein de sports depuis tout
petit et c'est ma vraie vraie vraie
passion et qu'aujourd'hui j'arrive à
j'ai la chance de pouvoir aussi
développé avec mon métier en étant
invité sur des émissions de sport etc
et il ya quelques années effectivement
j'ai découvert le pilotage et le sport
automobile et ça c'est devenu vrai je
suis devenu vraiment débile avec ça
l'agent peut on peut dire je suis devenu
un des essais avaient découvrez tout ce
qu'il faut tout ce que je peux faire je
vais je fais du karting toutes les
semaines je vais quand je fais mes
courses j'essaye d'aller le plus vite du
rayon des fruits et légumes aux surgelés
j'essaye de travailler les trajectoires
mon caddie non je suis devenu débile je
suis donc dit à l'oreillette entre la
frite et la salade
oui voilà exactement entre l'afrique et
la salade non mais c'est cette ope aussi
d'avoir donc quand on fait un métier
artistique comme ça d'avoir autre chose
d'avoir une autre passion qui vous sort
de ce truc très égocentré un peu mégalo
et est donc ça me fait un bien fou de
voilà d'être passionné par autre chose
et de ne pas être passionné que par moi
même en fait et ma carrière et je crois
que c'est assez salvateur aussi pour ma
mon bien-être psychique on se vante
d'être en train d'écrire il n'est pas le
moment le plus facile dans la vie d'un
artiste jusqu'en 2020 vous avez un
nouveau spectacle et que vous présentez
ans à versailles on jouit avant de faire
la cigale oui je peux vous en parler
c'est un spectacle donc que j'écris en
ce moment que je commencerai à jouer fin
mai et ranger fin mai juin notamment à
versailles donc au real factory c'est un
spectacle à nouveau one man dans lequel
je vais parler et évoquer ou en tous cas
me nourrir dans l'écriture des trois
dernières années de ma vie qui ont été
un peu dur et enfin dur disons que j'ai
vécu des choses pas cool et pour la
première fois je vais écrire en
nourrissant de ce qui m'est arrivé dans
la vie jusque là je le faisais pas parce
que j'avais une vie plutôt quelconque et
le truc le plus dingue qui m'était
arrivé c'était d'avoir volé des images
panini dans une librairie à l'âge de 12
ans mais bon ça fait pas un spectacle
mais j'étais au climax de la vie de
dingue est là depuis trois ans voilà
j'ai fait deux mariages deux divorces un
enfant j'ai perdu mon papa tout ça ça à
un moment donné quand on est humoriste
on se dit bon ben qu'est ce qu'on fait
de ça en fait ces paris
eh ben ça nourrit et puis on et puis on
peut écrire des choses très drôle autour
de tout ça alors les gens qui me
découvre dans cette émission vont se
dire entre le l'extrait qu'ils ont vu là
où il n'y avait pas un rire ou parler de
la mort de son père et de ses divorces
mais non ça va être très drôle on va on
va on va s'amuser avec tout ça mais
surtout que ce spectacle vous il est
produit par jérémy ferrari là aussi vous
retourner sur vos efforts et vos
collègues vos amis
oui j'ai la chance d'avoir des vrais
amis avec un grand à jérémy ont fait
partie qu'on précise ce qu'affirme de
monde que retient on fait rien alors on
avait créé une espèce de rivalités tous
les deux qui amusait beaucoup le public
et et on s'amusait beaucoup à se
détester dans la vie privée on s'aime
énormément et jérémy il a un parcours
incroyable il a développé une société de
production incroyable et
et j'ai décidé de travailler avec lui
sur ce nouveau spectacle parce que
jérémy dès qu'il ya quelqu'un qui va pas
bien lui c'est le plus beau jour de sa
vie donc donc
donc quand je lui ai dit écoute ça va
pas il m'est arrivé ça ça ça et tout il
dira oui c'est génial tu vas tu m'as
tellement fait rire les gens avec
certains y avait un humour assez
différent il est temps qu'un humour très
noir vous êtes dans un humour très
absurde et pourtant ça match oui ça m'a
juku oui parce que parce que enfin c'est
indicible l'amitié le lol la complicité
c'est ça on peut pas mal c'est comme
l'amour on peut on sait pas pourquoi
mais c'est comme ça et est il admire il
admire mon travail j'admire le sien et
et il a très envie que je sors tout ça
de moi et que j'écrive un spectacle qui
surprennent un petit peu les gens tout
en respectant ce que je suis cet humour
absurde en tout en allant là dedans
il m'a lui s'intéresse énormément que
j'aille chercher dans ce que j'ai vécu
ces trucs un peu ses trucs de vie qui
m'ont mis un peu à terre ces dernières
années il m'a dit vraiment rien il ya
quelque chose pour pour écrire un
nouveau spectacle à 45 ans et surprendre
le public avec quelque chose de qui va
mêler l'absurde la folie mais aussi le
vrai quoi le le sincère donc scellé vous
livrez donc ça spectacle ouais le livret
oui oui après ça se passe ce sera pas ce
sympathique aux thérapeutiques mais mais
en tout cas je vais me servir
ce sont des prétextes je vais me servir
de choses qui ne sont vraiment arrivés
et et puis on partira dans des dents
dans d'autres choses on a hâte de voir
ce que ça va donner parce qu'en face on
voit des petites vidéos sur twitter il
ne semble pas vous faciliter la tâche
dans ce petit placard de deux mètres
carrés voilà alors ça c'est une vidéo là
où il explique aux gens que je suis à la
prod ont travaillé je suis en train de
regarder
la patrouille que je travaille pas du
tout et donc il va mettre dans un
placard pour me forcer à écrire
pc c'est chouette parce qu'il a une
il a une vision de la promotion qui a
s'est cassé ma rente on fait plein de
passes tes vidéos et tout pour donner on
regarde ça ramène des souvenirs mais
justement on pourra voir tout ce
résultat les 24 et 25 juin prochains
c'est chez nous à 24 et 26 juin et 26
juin
donc ouais c'est grave alors juste j'ai
eu le temps de raconter un truc je vous
en prie on parler de la passion du sport
je devais jouer le 24 et le 25 et le 25
si j'ai réalisé qu'il y avait un match
de l'équipe de france à l'euro au foot
et j'ai demandé à décaler la date
je crois que le royal factory n'est pas
au courant de cette histoire je le dis
humblement
la production a donc fait chier pour
décaler la date au vieux crise mais non
mais c'est comme ça c'est la ccit
passionnés sinon sinon je peux pas
monter sur scène alors que l'équipe de
france joue à l'euro c'est pas possible
une oreillette peut-être pendant le
skate ouais peut-être je sais il ya des
acteurs comme ça qu'ils jouent avec un
écran télé en coulisses pour pouvoir
voir les matchs mais maintenant la jeune
24 et 26 juin à versailles et vous
pourrez voir là il sera tout juste sorti
de l'ordinateur c'est ce qu'on appelle
une date de rodage donc le public vient
avec cette indulgence cela en sachant
que le spectacle à rodez donc et et
voilà mais c'est toujours des moments
assez assez particulier de donner aux
gens la voient là la première mouture du
texte
merci de nous avoir accordé un peu de
temps et on a hâte donc de vous
découvrir à versailles le 24 juin
prochain
le
[Musique]